winning top honors in the documentary
category this year is directa one
jung-bae with a film Veera Clement blunt
edge it was made at Columbia College in
Chicago and follows the renowned Chicago
artist on the eve of her 80th birthday
as she discusses her life and her work
when I first showed my film tavera the
main subject she said to me huh I didn't
expect this much from you and then this
film later on when the Directors Guild
of America student film award you no
woman category and my mom congratulated
me from Korea saying good job well done
daughter but I can't see how bad or the
student must be since you're winning and
then but nobody can really taught my dad
ah when I showed a blunt edge to my dad
he gave me the best compliment ever I
received from my dad he said hmm it's
watchable yeah um huh and I I I think
about it you know that the fact that my
film is becoming a watchable in this up
in this industry of a filmmaking we're
only there Excel excellency survives and
that's the norm it is a tremendous task
to meet the expectation of general
audience normal people like my dad who
serve them are in for 36 years mmm I I
am when you mentally are thankful for
Academy for this creator encouragement
and love you Vera I learned so much from
you and happy birthday my mom and I love
you dad Chad and my teacher is I
columbia college chicago wen hua Bruce
Michael and Bill my great mentor in
Seattle
and Andrew you are my hero and you will
always be and thank you so much for the
great honor